welcome back i'm here with the other pee
in my culinary pod it's chef pilar
valdes
[Applause]
okay i am so excited because our
cookbook baby is almost out um it drops
on november 2nd okay um yeah i just said
drops
it's on pre-order now though so rebel
homemaker out this fall that's right and
pilar and i have worked very closely on
this book it is really a love letter
it's both of half of our hearts put into
one shape absolutely um and this month
we got something else to celebrate um
our friends at cherry bomb uh they are
an incredible
sort of um if you are a chef this is the
tippity top it's like it's a wonderful
place that really champions women in
food so they have the magazine
um there also they also do in-person and
live events which are really amazing
they have a tremendous podcast their
covers feature padma lakshmi martha
stewart you know
to name a few every important and
interesting chef and i had a dream that
maybe one day
pilar and i would be
uh on cherry bomb which was just like
such a pipe dream anyway we're so
honored because this month that dream
came true
[Applause]
we're cover girls and we can't wait to
show you are you ready
yep
okay here we go one two three cherry
bomb
[Applause]
i want to thank you
especially our dear friend carrie
diamond who is not just the
editor-in-chief she is the woman who
helps other women
takes care of restaurants and really is
just a champion for all things in the
culinary world absolutely thank you
cherry bomb for having us
[Music]
you